bonjour patrick mignola bonjour à tous
merci d'être parmi nous pour ce
lancement de la saison de l'association
des journalistes parlementaires alors
que commence la dernière session avant
les élections de l'année prochaine
bon pas besoin de vous présenter mes
quelques mots vous êtes député modem de
la 4e circonscription de la savoie
depuis 2018 vous présidez le groupe à
vous m'entendez oui voilà c'est prêt
depuis 2018 vous présidez le groupe
modem vous avez pris la succession de
marc raynaud qui est entré au
gouvernement avant d'être député vous
avez été conseiller général de la savoie
maire de la ravoire vice président du
conseil régional auvergne rhône-alpes et
vous êtes aujourd'hui à la tête d'un
groupe qui a connu une certaine
expansion et même une expansion
certaines au cours du quinquennat
puisque vous avez gagné une dizaine de
députés pour être aujourd'hui 57 au sein
du groupe modem et démocrate apparenté
on se parlera d'ailleurs des contours de
la majorité tout à l'heure mais pour
commencer une première question de
chantal didier questions d'actualité
monsieur le président
bon les prix de l'énergie qui flambe un
bouclier tarifaire qui n'a pas l'air de
boucler beaucoup de choses de défendre
beaucoup de choses
les manifestations d'hier pour la hausse
des salaires est ce que on entre dans
une phase plus sociale
au plan politique économique et
finalement est ce que les questions
sociales ne vont pas dominer la campagne
présidentielle plutôt que d'éventuelles
questions d'identité d'immigration et
autres
et d'autres sujets polémiques en tous
cas ce serait souhaitable effectivement
qu'on passe pas tout la campagne
électorale à parler uniquement de
questions identitaires mais option
pourra y revenir évidemment
je crois exactement ce que vous dites
celle que je pense que
après une année et demie extrêmement
difficile à nulle autre pareille
au terme d'une espérance en soit le
terme d'une crise sanitaire inédite
nous connaissons mal ce que seront les
effets psychologiques et donc sociaux
sur les français
mais ce que je pressens avec mes
collègues du groupe démocrate c'est que
dans cette relance économique il faudra
qu'ils aient une relance sociale
et pour deux raisons à la fois parce que
nous avons besoin de reconstruire une
croissance pour ce pays on va voter le
budget
la semaine prochaine le cycle a commencé
la grande question que se posent les
français c'est est ce qu'on aura des
impôts à payer pour financer tout ce qui
a été dépensé pour soutenir l'économie
pour soutenir l'hôpital au cours de ces
18 mois et la solution que nous avons
préconisé avec la majorité c'est que ce
soit une part de la croissance que nous
avons retrouvée qui finance les dépenses
plutôt que une augmentation des impôts
qui pourrait que l'enrayer
c'est mieux qu'un pari c'est une réalité
puisqu'on atteint aujourd'hui un taux de
croissance de presque 7% un des
meilleurs taux de croissance de l'union
européenne est tant mieux donc je crois
qu'on avait bien calibrée ce plan de
relance
mais au moment où les français
comprennent que en fait c'est par la
croissance c'est par une rentabilité
retrouvée donc c'est par leur travail
qu'on va pouvoir assumer et passé ceci
mauvais moment dans l'histoire de notre
pays bas il ya assez naturellement la
question des salaires qui se pose
et qui s'ajoute au fait que dans tous
les budgets de toutes les familles en
france
il ya eu de nouvelles dépenses
obligatoires de nouvelles charges fixes
et moi je n'entrerai pas dans la
polémique
mais en fait vous avez augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat voulait augmenter
en fait on a augmenté les recettes dans
toutes les familles françaises et en
particulier les plus modestes en
baissant les impôts en baissant les
charges en permettant d'avoir des primes
macron en favorisant des négociations de
branche pour les augmentations
salariales mais si les recettes ont
augmenté par schématiquement les 50
milliards de baisses d'impôts et de
charges qu'on a voté au cours de ce
quinquennat vous avez aussi les dépenses
qui ont augmenté au premier rang
desquels le logement
parce que vous parlez de l'énergie je
vais revenir dans un instant mais la
question du logement est une question
majeure sur laquelle on doit travailler
absolument avec les élus locaux parce
qu'on peut pas avoir un prix du logement
qui augmente de 5% par an et qui au
cours d'une législature comme celle-là a
totalement à zahlé les augmentations de
pouvoir d'achat qu'on a octroyé aux
français vous avez la question de
l'énergie qui aujourd'hui se pose en
termes conjoncturel c'est à dire qu'il
ya une très forte demande mondiale donc
le prix de l'énergie montrent et c'est
pour ça qu'il fallait apporter cette
bonne réponse parce qu'elle est
immédiate elle est pas bonne parce
qu'elles règlent le problème
définitivement vous avez raison mais le
renvoi le coup
non mais surtout elle renvoie le coup
jusqu'au moment où ils peuvent envoyer
une stabilisation des cours de l'énergie
et des cours du carburant c'est-à-dire
le les prévisions qui nous sont donnés
aujourd'hui c'est qu'à partir du mois
d'avril mai prochain on reviendra à des
niveaux de prix du pétrole et du prix du
gaz qui seront plus accessibles pour les
français donc
la question ce qui évidemment il faudra
qu'on règle le problème à moyen terme du
prix de l'énergie et de l'indépendance
énergétique parce que si le la question
de l'énergie pour les français c'est de
savoir si on est dépendant au gaz russe
comme le sont les allemands aujourd'hui
c'est une question fondamentale qui est
même plus géopolitique mais il faut
régler le problème pour madame martin à
chambéry lundi
avant de penser une géopolitique et des
investissements dans des énergies
nouvelles en france et ça ça passait par
le chèque énergie est pas le bouclier
tarifaire qui a été mis en place mais
vous voyez bien que derrière tout ça
il ya la question du rapport au travail
de la rémunération du travail et du fait
que on doit engager le pays dans un
cycle vertueux
on doit tous travailler à retaper
l'économie pour que ça recréer
des ressources pour nos budgets
nationaux et locaux et pour faire en
sorte que on alourdissent pas les
épaules de nos enfants de la dette
accumulée depuis 18 mois alors une
petite précision ans chantal m'a demandé
de ne pas oublier tout à l'heure et
évidemment j'ai oublié notre rencontre
est diffusée sur le canal de l'assemblée
ou pouvoir trouver ça sur le sur le site
et puis on tweet live est également sûr
@ agi parlement avec stanislas noyer
questions complémentaires sur cette
question du prix de l'énergie hier jean
castex a évoqué la possibilité
éventuellement d'agir sur le levier
fiscal si le prix du gaz continuent à
augmenter si cela devient nécessaire au
printemps est ce que ça vous paraît
suffisant est-ce que la réponse
immédiate du gouvernement et suffisante
ou est ce que vous envisagez
éventuellement travers le budget de de
prendre des initiatives sur le sujet si
dans les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines les prix continuent de
s'envoler aujourd'hui la réponse est
suffisante mais c'est aujourd'hui et on
n'est pas dans un art divinatoire
on est dans une pratique politique on
peut pas deviner ce que sera le prix de
l'énergie dans deux mois ou dans quatre
mois dans ces conditions de toute façon
vous avez deux leviers vous avez le
levier de la tei pp flottante qu'on a
déjà utilisé par le passé pour adapter
le niveau des taxes au niveau de
l'énergie en tant que matière première
et vous avez la question de la tva sur
l'énergie avec
un élément quel mon avis on doit
désormais régler absolument c'est que
voilà on peut on peut pas continuer à
payer de la tva sur la tva cercle sur la
facture de tous les français d'énergie
vous avez non seulement l'énergie mais
vous avez aussi un certain nombre de
prestations qui sont soumises à tva et
vous mettez de la tva sur la tva il ya
guère que en france que
le l'explosivité fiscal de l'imagination
persiennes est capable de créer de la
tva au carré donc voilà ce serait déjà
le premier élément qui me paraîtrait
assez sain après vous avez un autre
sujet c'est à dire que nous savons de
toute façon que sur les dix ans qui
viennent le prix de l'énergie augmentera
en particulier le prix du gaz on prévoit
une augmentation de 30 à 40 % du prix du
gaz est là se posera la question de la
fiscalité écologique il faut le prendre
par le bon bout il faut pas que ce soit
une fiscalité punitive ont dit bah de
toute façon on va taxer par principe le
l'ensemble des énergies il faut que nous
procédions si on veut vraiment lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
par substitution et car une partie de la
fiscalité traditionnels se substitue la
fiscalité écologique la fiscalité
écologique elle peut pas venir en plus
de la fiscalité traditionnelle alors
nous vivons dans déjà dans un pays qui
est un des plus fiscalisé de l' ocde
même si depuis cinq ans dabo coûts
baisser les impôts et cette mécanique là
c'est aussi une mécanique vertueuse
qu'il faut proposer aux français c'est
demain bien sûr si nous voulons lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique il
faut décarbonés l'économie française
pour la déclare bonney ça passera par
une fiscalité écologique mais il faut qu
à due concurrence on baisse la fiscalité
traditionnelle et moi je pense depuis
très longtemps que à un moment la
question de la tva écologique va se
poser mais ce sera pas pour en rajouter
ce sera pour la réduire est ce que si
demain vous décidé de créer une
fiscalité écologique pour gommer tous
des comportements plus vertueux et que
ça représente 40 milliards de fiscalité
écologique à 40 milliards ces deux
points de tva et donc il faudra en tirer
les conséquences sur la tva et là vous
avez une réponse de moyen long terme
à la halle au gotha sion inéluctable des
cours de l'énergie oui le haut
commissaire au plan qui est quelqu'un
que vous connaissez bien à données
publiées une note ya pas très longtemps
et quelques mois en disant qu' il
fallait absolument qu'on relancer
l'industrie nucléaire
l'électricité nucléaire et qui aurait
pas de transition écologique sans
nucléaire et en particulier dit
carrément les 6 p r que demander un
certain rapport demandent 'est-ce que
vous approuvez ce point de vue est ce
que on peut faire une transition
écologique sans le nucléaire ça va vous
étonner beaucoup que shaw d'accord avec
françois bâillon
mais
voyez le l'avantagé d'avoir un
commissariat au plan à nouveau c'est
précisément ça permet de poser les
sujets de façon sereine
on a beaucoup parlé du nucléaire et on
sait ce que peut représenter le risque
principal du nucléaire c'est à dire le
traitement des déchets dans la durée et
ça ça nécessite un investissement massif
dans la recherche scientifique pour que
on lève cette question là mais il est
évident que le nucléaire est une énergie
décarbonée
et que chaque jour qui passe si on
compare les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de la france est celle de
l'allemagne on voit que ce sont des
rapports de 1 à 5 c'est à dire que de
toute façon vous ne ferez pas de
l'énergie décarbonée vous ne ferez pas
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
si vous n'utilisez pas de l'énergie
décarbonée et le nucléaire est la
première d'entre elles
l'hydroélectricité et 7 un savoyard
c'est un alpin qui vous parle en est une
deuxième et vous avez naturellement les
énergies renouvelables dont les
éoliennes qui font tant polémique parce
que vous avez remarqué que lors des
élections régionales on a plus parlé de
sécurité et d'éoliennes que le sujet qui
concernait les régions
vous touchez là du doigt ce que doit
être la cohérence dans ce que dit un
commissariat au plan voilà qui pose les
objectifs du pays à horizon cinq à dix
ans et ce quel débat politique où moi je
le regrette beaucoup que
le les écologistes aujourd'hui
renoncent
à des mesures de bon sens pouvait pas
décarbonés l'énergie si vous luttez
aussi contre le nucléaire pouvait pas
déclarent bonne et l'énergie si les
mêmes qui veulent décarbonés l'énergie
portent des pancartes contre les
éoliennes contre les champs solaires
contre la biomasse contre la
méthanisation et même contre les
barrages hydroélectriques parce que ça
abîme les poissons ce qui est totalement
faux d'ailleurs puisque désormais on
crée des passes à poissons dans les
barrages pour éviter que les poissons ne
souffre des barrages voyez c'est c'est
toute la difficulté
désormais on n'est plus dans le dire en
matière de transition écologique on est
dans le faire et dans le faire il faut
abandonner
les propos idéologique
et je comprends qu'il ya un certain
nombre de militants écologistes qui
habille initiaux se soit engagé
politiquement contre un certain nombre
de projets mais si aujourd'hui ce sont
ces projets qui nous permettent de
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique faut simplement changé son
fusil d épaule est passée du
militantisme à la responsabilité
politique les questions sur ce sujet
éventuellement
en revanche je suis opposé à la
proposition de dany d'algos
de faire immédiatement une baisse
massive
de la taxe sur les carburants je suis
persuadé que ça coûterait rien à paris
puisque les voitures est en plus en plus
interdits de circuler dans la capitale
finalement c'est qu'outre est assez peu
de carburant donc assez peu au budget de
l'état mais je pense qu'il y aurait là
une totale incohérence avec les
orientations courageuse qu'on doit
prendre en matière de transition
énergétique
autre sujet d'actualité douloureux
comment avez vous réagi à la publication
du rapport sauvé le pape a fait part de
son immense chagrin est ce que la
justice des hommes est ce que est ce que
le pouvoir politique a son mot à dire
à ce sujet ou est-ce que c'est à
l'église aujourd'hui de
tirer les conséquences de ce rapport il
y avait une demande de commission
denquête ici à quelques années qu'il
n'avait pas finalement été mise en place
comment est ce que vous avez réagi avec
vous en dire
moi je crois qu'on répond pas à de tels
drames humains par des commissions
d'enquêté qui sont la réponse de ceux
qui ne veulent pas tout à fait en
apporter d'abord le rapport de jean marc
sauvé est un rapport remarquable
c'est un travail qui a été fait avec une
très grand souci de transparence très
grand souci de responsabilité et d
équilibre
et moi je veux penser à tous ceux qui
sont
cons été blessés dans leur chair et dans
leur esprit
sur cette période je veux penser à ceux
qui sont blessés dans leur foi
catholique aussi parce que c'est c'est
un coup de tonnerre pour le l'ensemble
de l'église catholique
et la première réflexion qui vient à
l'esprit c'est
mais quelle est cette société qui a pu
en arriver
à de telles extrémités ou à détourner le
regard
je pense que
[Musique]
il faut regarder ce rapport sauvé
en faisant
une réflexion d'apaisement
moi je suis sûr que l'église prendra ses
responsabilités
et saura trouver les voies et moyens
pour que l'on aille vers un plus jamais
ça et qu'on aille vers une indemnisation
des victimes ça ne répare rien mais ça
aide à surmonter ce qui a été vécu en
revanche on assiste là
à ce qu'est le la nécessaire
transparence et le rapport à la vérité
dans notre société
je trouve très bien que
on puisse ouvrir tous les dossiers qu'on
puisse affronter tous les drames
est ce que dit le rapport sauvé vous
savez c c'est pas une évolution récente
de la société moderne c'est probablement
ce qui se passait il ya 20 50 et parfois
200 ans mais aujourd'hui parce qu'on vit
dans une société de transparence ou la
vérité est immédiate ou à travers les
chaînes d'information continue
l'exigence de nos concitoyens de savoir
on met des lumière crue
sur des réalités qui était souvent
ignorés
et au fond
on est on est tous ceux bouleversé
parfois secoué
en voyant le traitement qui est réservé
aux femmes à kaboul en même temps
qu'on regarde
les yeux dans les yeux
ce qui était la réalité de la pédophilie
dans l'église
moi je n'y vois pas une régression de la
société je n'y vois pas un effondrement
de nos valeurs j'y voit au contraire un
progrès une société qui est capable de
regarder ces problèmes en face et des
problèmes qui existaient peut-être
depuis des millénaires
eh bien je pense au contraire que c'est
une société qui va de l'avant et il faut
parfois supporter
que enfin on s'attaque au problème que
enfin on les connaît ce qu'on les donne
à voir
à nos concitoyens
et si parfois certains en tirent des
conséquences de leur propre vie mans
2-2 révolte
il faut leur dire que au contraire
c'est le signe d'une civilisation
moderne
de pouvoir affronter tous les problèmes
y compris ce que les générations qui
nous ont précédés n'avait pas su régler
et en cela ce que ce qu'a fait la
commission sauvé
je pense que c'est un des éléments qui
marquera cette décennie sur la voie
d'une société
on
peut mieux vivre ensemble
présentez vous à chaque fois votre nom
et médias s'il vous plaît gervais
horizons politiques à propos de
l'indemnisation
le président des évêques ce matin l'air
de dire que ça va être très difficile
dans la mesure où l'église
ne peut pas vendre les églises etc et
est ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible vraiment que
l'église de france
adam nice chaque
chaque victime et comment pourrait-elle
le faire alors je crois même que c'est
nécessaire
et le la question n'est pas le montant
d'indemnisation parce que aucune somme
ne saurait effacer
ce j'allais dire ce péché ses péchés en
tout cas c'est vécu et ses drames en
revanche
il faut qu' il y est indemnisation pour
reconnaître la faute parce que vous
savez tout ça c'est comme dans un deuil
quand il ya eu l'assassinât d'un enfant
si on a retrouvé l'assassin et les
cookies les condamner ça rend pas
l'enfant à ses parents
mais en revanche ça leur permet de mieux
avancer dans le dans le chemin du deuil
et de la même façon je pense que sur ces
crimes et c'est d'ailleurs françois
bayrou qui le premier l'avait proposé il
y a quelques années
je suis pas favorable à ce que demain il
ya une
imprescriptibilité
de ce type de crime parce que l'
imprescriptibilité elle est réservée aux
crimes contre l'humanité mais dans ces
crimes contre l'humanite en ce qu'il
doit y avoir des procès quand même même
si les faits sont prescrits
parce que le fait que la société disent
que la faute est reconnue
et mérite condamnation
le fait que le procès se tienne
c'est quasiment aussi important
que l'accomplissement de la peine
imaginez des condamnations qui ne serait
pas suivi d'effet en sommes exactement
parce que vous allez vous retrouver avec
des personnes qui peuvent avoir 85 à 95
ans
sur lesquels il faut porter
le regard de la société
et qui une condamnation de la société à
défaut d'une mise sous les verrous
demain d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale sera notamment marquée par
l'examen d'une proposition de loi
d'aurélien pradié dans le cadre de la
journée d'initiative parlementaire du
groupe l'est républicain
une proposition de loi en faveur de
l'autonomie des personnes en situation
de handicap et va revenir un sujet qui a
fait débat il y a quelques mois déjà ici
dans le cadre d'une autre proposition de
loi présentée à l'époque par liberté et
territoires qui concerne notamment la d
conjugale isation 2
l'allocation adulte handicapé la semaine
dernière en commission cette disposition
a été rejetée par la majorité pour
quelles raisons et est-ce que vous
assumez cette position alors qu'on le
voit bien depuis quelques mois depuis au
fil de la législature les niches
parlementaires sont devenus un piège
politique pour la majorité le
gouvernement
oui en fait le plus important c'est le
sujet qu'on évoque
je déteste cette manière
d'exploiter par les oppositions à chaque
niche parlementaire
des sujets qui sont des sujets très
importants mais qu'il n'utilise que
comme un joker et politique qui tape
très fort dans la balle pour qu'elle
nous revienne dans la gueule
on enfin de parler de quoi on est en
train de parler d'une injustice sociale
il y à des personnes qui sont des
personnes handicapées dans notre pays et
qui parce qu'elles sont mariées à
quelqu'un qui gagne bien sa vie ne
peuvent pas bénéficier de l'allocation
adulte handicapé et quelque part parce
qu'on serait tombé amoureux de quelqu'un
qui gagne bien sa vie et bien finalement
la société ne reconnaît pas le handicap
comporte ce qui invite d'ailleurs à ne
pas se marier après est donc assez
naturellement ouais mais le système du
foyer fiscal fait que de toute façon un
moment voilà on peut y compris
voulez-vous supprimer l'âge c'est une
injustice
une justice on doit la règle est la
première idée qui vient à l'esprit c'est
évidemment de déconvenues égaliser être
considéré que en matière d'attribution
de l'allocation adulte handicapé il faut
que l'on paye la hache quel que soit le
niveau de ressources du conjoint
souvent la première idée est pas la
bonne c'est ce qu'on s'est efforcé
d'expliquer encore la semaine dernière
après l'avoir expliqué il ya trois mois
et d'avoir expliqué il ya six mois en
arrière c'est que ça va faire des
gagnants dans les cas que je viens de
décrire mais ça fait aussi des perdants
parce qu'il peut arriver que des
personnes handicapées travaille-t-elle
même
gagnent bien leur vie soit mariée à un
conjoint ou une conjointe qui elle gagne
moins bien sa vie et dans ce cas là si
vous des conjugue alizés elle va perdre
le bénéfice de la hache qu'en face à une
injustice sociale au moment où vous
prenez une mesure pour la règle et vous
régler pour un certain nombre de gens
mais en règle et vous créer des
problèmes avec d'autres c'est que c'est
pas le bon chemin et le bon chemin je le
répète pour avoir été vous l'avez bien
voulu le rappeler conseiller
départemental ya quelques années le bon
chemin ce n'est pas là des conjugale
isation de lâches c'est la prise en
charge à travers la pch la prestation de
compensation du handicap c'est à dire
les fonds qui sont distribués par les
départements en partenariat avec l'état
pour que toute personne handicapée
puisse dans l'organisation de sa vie
personnelle au quotidien ou de sa vie
professionnelle puisse disposer de
sommes en investissement ou dans son
quotidien qui lui permettent de aménager
son lieu de vie aménager son espace de
travail avoir un véhicule avoir un
accompagnement parce que la pch là pour
le coup elle est personnalisé elle porte
bien son nom c'est une allocation de
prestation de compensation du handicap
et donc moi j'ai appelé le gouvernement
d'ailleurs à travailler très vite avec
l'assemblée des départements de france a
un nouveau président qui est françois
sauvadet qui connaît très bien ces
sujets là je l'avais évoqué auparavant
avec dominique bussereau et il vaut bien
mieux que au plfss sur le budget de la
sécurité sociale nous travaillons à un
budget supplémentaire accordé aux
départements pour accompagner les
personnes handicapées qui aujourd'hui ne
disposerait pas d'âge pour des raisons
de conjugale isation mais qu'en revanche
on ne coupe pas la hache à des personnes
qui souffrira de la dea conjugale
isation elle même voilà et donc ce débat
est une démagogie face à un problème on
apporte une solution et on essaye pas
d'en faire un sujet de polémique et de
guérilla parlementaire pourquoi vous
n'avez pas encore adopté votre
proposition parce que comme vous l'avez
remarqué le plfss arrive dans un mois
voilà mais de toute évidence le mot
collègues pradier dont je ne conteste
pas l'engagement sincère sur ces
sujets-là
fait semblant de ne pas comprendre et à
trouver
cette date très opportune de la niche
parlementaire réservée aux républicains
pour laisser croire que cette majorité
manquerait de générosité et d'écouté
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap je n'ai aucune difficulté a dit
qu' il n'y a eu aucune majorité avant
nous qu'elle soit de droite de gauche ou
d'ailleurs qui à l'assemblée nationale
est votée autant de mesures sociales
supplémentaires pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
entre les textes budgétaires les
prochains jours les prochaines semaines
à l'assemblée vont également être
marquée par le débat sur le nouveau
projet de loi qui sera présenté la
semaine prochaine en conseil des
ministres sur la question de l'épidémie
tco vide avec notamment
dans le projet de loi qui sera présenté
la possibilité de prolonger
l'utilisation du pass sanitaire porte
parole du gouvernement gabriela talent a
dit récemment que le gouvernement
voulait permettre
cette possibilité ce qui veut pas dire
que le past and i terre restera en
vigueur tout ce temps là mais permettre
cette possibilité jusqu'à l'été en mai
dernier sur ce sujet là le groupe modem
avait voté contre un article qui
comprenait notamment le passé ni terre
pour des questions de calendrier est-ce
qu envisagée cette prolongation dès
aujourd'hui jusqu'à l'été après la
présidentielle vous semble vous semble
acceptable
alors moi je pense que oui et je dis
d'autant plus facilement qu'on a été
très attentif à ce que l'assemblée
depuis le début de l'épidémie le
parlement en général soient
systématiquement au contrôle de ce que
fait le gouvernement parce qu'évidemment
quand on prend des mesures qui sont
restrictives de liberté publique pour
nos concitoyens il est important que le
parlement soit au contrôle en
l'occurrence
nous avons l'obligation la
responsabilité politique de nous donner
tous les moyens de faire face à un
éventuel report épidémique ou à une
adaptation de nos mesures en fonction
des évolutions territoriale on pense
bien sûr à nos compatriotes d'outre-mer
mais ça peut être des évolutions
territorialisée très différentes on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui les foyers
épidémiques qui demeure ne sont pas du
tout les mêmes selon les parties du
territoire donc on a la responsabilité
de le faire mais on passe à des
dispositions qui sont d'une autre nature
et on passe c'est la proposition d'air
j'avais fait pour l'incarner on passe
d'une situation d'urgence sanitaire et
une situation de vigilance et à jouer
sur les mots là annonce parce que pour
les français urgence evidian c'est pas
tout à fait pareil l'état d'urgence
sécuritaire
et le plan vigipirate c'est pas la même
chose l'état d'urgence sécuritaire c'est
se donner la possibilité d'aller vers
des restrictions de liberté très forte
et avoir quasiment des lois d'exception
le plan vigipirate c'est être en
situation de vigilance à chaque fois que
il ya un risque terroriste qui remonte
et passe et on peut faire l'analogie
avec ce qu'on va faire en matière
sanitaire
cette loi est plutôt une loi de sortie
qu'une loi de prolongation et pourquoi
au fond je vous dis que je suis
favorable à ce que l'on puisse
se doter de ce cadre légal jusqu'au mois
de juillet prochain c'est parce que vous
l'ignorez ici moins que quiconque
l'assemblée sera de siéger le 15 février
et ça signifierait si on a encore un
risque épidémique conre convoque le
parlement
entre le 1er et le 15 février prochain
pour voter de nouveau un cadre
d'urgence ou de vigilance sanitaire en
fonction de la situation
je suis pas beaucoup d'expérience
politique ça fait 26 ans que je suis élu
mais je tire une conséquence de ce qui
s'est passé depuis 18 mois à chaque fois
que nous avons eu un texte sur la
situation sanitaire
il y en a eu 11
les oppositions
de façon systématique
ont voté contre et quel que soit le
sujet que ce soit pour l'entrée en état
d'urgence que ce soit pour la sortie en
état d'urgence que ce soit pour la
création du pass que ce soit pour la
vaccination systématiquement ont voté
contre ben moi je me dis que notre
responsabilité vis-à-vis des français
c'est pas de lait de prendre en otage
leur santé parce que les oppositions
entre le 1er et le 15 février prochain à
deux mois du premier tour des élections
présidentielles auront envie encore une
fois de faire les malins dans
l'hémicycle moi je pense qu'on s'occupe
de la santé des français et qu'on n'est
pas là pour aller se taper sur la figure
en hémicycle deux jours et deux nuits
comme on l'a fait 11 fois d'affilée
depuis 18 mois
si les oppositions avait
une once
du nid et nationales à l'esprit
bon on pourrait se dire on va jusqu'à
février et puis on février
éventuellement on votera un autre texte
moi je pense qu'il faut voter un texte
aujourd'hui qui laisse toutes les
possibilités qui ne ferme aucune porte
et certainement pas celle de sortir de
toutes ces contraintes
du port des masques et de l'utilisation
du pass sanitaire mais que
valence on se met pas en situation
de créer de la guérilla parlementaire là
on a juste besoin de responsabilité nous
qui avons vécu pas mal de campagne
électorale aussi
un observateur en général quand il ya
des appels à l'union nationale ça sent
quand même sans argument électoral non
pas pourtant il ya 18 mois il n'y avait
pas deux il n'y avait pas de d'élections
en cours mais quand on regarde avait dit
quand vous dites quelle satisfaction
avait une once de sentiment d'une bise
aurait pu le faire qu'il n'y avait pas
d'élection il ya franchement ça aurait
coûté quoi aux oppositions de voter le
pass sanitaire avec nos mots de juillet
assez difficile il fallait un peu
courageux ce qu'il y avait 60 % des
français qui étaient contre le pass
sanitaire un joli il ya 90 % qui sont
pour enfin à l'époque fallait plus de
courage qu'il en soit aujourd'hui je
rappelle que le groupe des républicains
a voté contre le passé ni terre au mois
de juillet alors que le groupe des
républicains au sénat avait voté pour
c'est à dire qu'ils sont arrivés non
seulement à voter contre une loi du
gouvernement mais
contre aussi la position qui était celle
de gérard larcher et bruno retailleau
belge à un moment donné
si on n'est pas capable de faire de la
politique avec un peu de têtes et dans
ce cas là la majorité prend ses
responsabilités à défaut que
l'opposition de l'épreuve mais j'observe
que c'est même en période électorale
c'était la même chose voire à plus de la
question des municipal
c'est des choses qui m'ont un peu
marquer moi qui a été maire la veille au
soir tout le monde hurlait pour que les
élections municipales se tiennent le
lendemain de la tenue du premier tour
ils nous insultaient tous parce qu'elle
s'était tenue enfin bon et voilà oui
demandez vous pourquoi
les candidats de l air et du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui dans les sondages
sont en train de prendre l'eau toboggan
il n'y a rien d'étonnant un moment donné
les français ils présentent la facture
quand ils ont vu des gens qui ont
abandonné tout esprit de responsabilité
demande que le gouvernement
demande un vote du parlement sur la
réforme de la haute fonction publique
donc
ils disent que le parlement doit
intervenir donner son avis est ce que
vous êtes des sénateurs centristes
en l'occurrence le juge moi je suis
toujours de l'avis des sénateurs
centristes comme des députés centristes
parce que cette famille politique n'a
jamais cessé d'être la mienne je
constate ce qui vient de se passer au
sénat
ou au fond partant d'un bon sentiment
considérer que le parlement pouvait
s'exprimer au moins dans un débat sur la
réforme de la fonction publique et je
pense que de ce point de vue là
il ya des choix
c'est courageux du gouvernement qui ont
été faits mais qu'on pouvait interrogé
sur le recrutement dans la préfectorale
sur la peau cité de passerelles entre
les différents grands corps sur la
question de du devenir de la très haute
fonction publique et moi je suis pas de
ceux qui critiquent les hauts
fonctionnaires je pense qu'au contraire
si vous regardez bien ce qui s'est passé
depuis 18 mois si l'état a tenu même
quand il ya eu des ratés c'est
précisément parce que nos institutions
peuvent s'appuyer sur des hauts
fonctionnaires de grande qualité
mais
dans le débat au sein de la haute
assemblée vous avez observé que tous
ceux que vous avez cités de tous les
groupes sénatoriaux qui souhaitait
pouvoir débattre de la réforme de la
haute fonction publique n'ont pas été
capables de s'entendre entre eux et
qu'ils vont cet après-midi voter contre
leurs propres lois
il me semble donc tout ça partait d'un
bon sentiment mais que dans
l'application
les oppositions une fois encore ont
perdu une occasion d'être responsable
oui bonjour nathalie mort et pourrait
bras je sais que chambéry c'est assez
loin du havre mais je voulais savoir si
vous y seriez ce week end première
question est ce qu est ce que vous
pensez de la création de ce nouveau
parti deuxième question est ce que vous
avez peur que ça vous coûte déplace à
vous groupe modem lors des prochaines
législatives
je vous confirme que chambéry est loin
du havre et que pour le quatrième
week-end consécutif je vais être loin de
base ce qui me navre parce que j'aurais
préféré être sur le marché de chambéry
samedi matin mais je serai oif parce que
c'est politiquement important
est ce que vous l'avez observé
on a pris l'initiative cet été de
rapprocher les deux mouvements
principaux de la majorité présidentielle
la république en marche et le mouvement
démocrate pour que enfin
l'espace central de la vie politique
française se structure c'était
finalement un des derniers espaces
politiques au coeur de la vie politique
qui ne s'était pas structuré en france
je pense qu'on a besoin de cette
cohérence et une fois qu'on aura posé
cette cohérence
je suis persuadé qu'on aura aussi besoin
d'alliances
et que les alliances peuvent se faire
avec
une droite modérée
qui compte tenu
des débats qui traversent la droite en
ce moment dans le cadre de la
préparation des élections
présidentielles mais au fond tout ça
dure depuis quasiment une dizaine
d'années a besoin aussi de s'organiser
et il est utile que edouard philippe
comme christian estrosi comme hubert
falco prennent des initiatives de ce
point de vue là et au fond depuis 2012
et la campagne présidentielle de nicolas
sarkozy la droite oscille hésite entre
une ligne identitaire et une ligne
libérale
et aujourd'hui beaucoup cours vers où
derrière la ligne identitaire et je suis
persuadé qu'il ya un grand nombre d'élus
locaux mais tout simplement d'électeurs
de droite
qui sont mal à l'aise
avec cette course compte
et de ce point de vue là je trouve le
l'initiative d'edouard philippe utile et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me
rendrai avec christophe castaner
d'ailleurs parce que
même si on n'est pas de la même famille
ça n'interdit pas d'avoir des amis
j'appelle de mes voeux d'ailleurs
qu'à gauche il ya le même type de
réaction parce que entre la gauche
communautariste et la gauche
universaliste il ya des différences et
que la gauche universaliste pourrait
aussi utilement s'organiser je le dis
pourquoi
parce qu'évidemment pour remporter une
élection présidentielle est chouette que
le président de la république soit
candidat et soit réélu on aura besoin de
la base électorale la plus large
possible et surtout au lendemain
si les électeurs ne faisait confiance on
aura besoin de s'appuyer sur une
majorité
plus large et lèche parle pas de place à
l'assemblée mais
en ayant toujours en tête
le rêve qui était celui de valéry
giscard d'estaing de deux français sur
trois
lorsqu'il faudra prendre des mesures
difficiles en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
lorsqu'il faudra
réformer notre protection sociale et en
particulier les retraites lorsqu'il
faudra relancer l'économie et veillez à
ce que on augmente les salaires à
travers des systèmes de participation
d'intéressement d'actionnariat salarié
qui permettent de tirer tout le monde
vers le haut on aura besoin
d'être de s'appuyer sur des courants de
pensée différents mais susceptibles de
travailler ensemble quand il faudra
réformer les institutions quand il
faudra rééquilibrer les pouvoirs et on
voit bien le déséquilibre entre exécutif
et législatif on voit aussi les
questions qu'ils se posent sur le
pouvoir judiciaire lorsqu'il faudra
lutter contre les gaffes à lorsqu'il
faudra je l'espère décidé de mode de
scrutin plus représentatif des français
lorsqu'il faudra revoir le mille feuille
territorial pour qu'enfin ils puissent
être compris et qu'il ya une
organisation de terrain qu'ils soient
enfin plus pertinente et qui ressemble
à ce à quoi les français aspirent dans
leur gestion locale pour le 21e siècle
tout ça ça ne se fera pas si nous ne
restons qu'entre nous
parce que sinon les mêmes causes
produiront les mêmes effets on aura
probablement une majorité
disons qu'elle pourrait être plus courte
que la dernière fois mais on aura une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale donc
les 18 premiers mois ça se passera très
bien et comme d'habitude
comme depuis toutes les législatures
précédentes au bout de 18 mois le moteur
va serrer
parce que c'est normal quand on est aux
responsabilités il ya une forme d'usure
du pouvoir et un moment donné il ya des
incompréhensions qui s'instille avec
l'opinion publique c'est là qu'il faudra
pouvoir s'allier et posé notre action
sur des bases plus large le le drame de
ce pays merveilleux
c'est que
les quinquennat comme l'amour dure deux
ans alors que l'amour peut durer plus
longtemps que deux ans moi je crois que
lé quinquennat doivent durer cinq ans
pour qu'on puisse agir et former ce pays
dans de bonnes conditions est ce que
vous vous trouvez que votre amie et
alliée à douar fibre ou favorisent cette
cette vision un peu et irénique du futur
quinquennat en prônant une retraite à 67
ans
et j'ai bien lu le
sujet des 67 ans et le
la réponse qui a été apporté par
françois bayrou sur ce que doit demeurer
notre contrat social
je crois assez bien connaître le sujet
des retraites
et je pense
contrairement à beaucoup que ça n'est
pas un sujet politique mais que c'est un
sujet technique
est au fond le débat qui a lieu
aujourd'hui sur la question du 67 ans
c'est le débat que les syndicats
connaissent bien d un sur l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite et la durée de
cotisation et moi je pense que de ce que
d'ailleurs la position constante de la
cfdt sur ce sujet qu'il faut parler
durée de cotisation parce que l'âge de
67 ans il est
il est choquant pour un certain nombre
de français qui travaillent dans des
métiers difficiles etc ont commencé tôt
à travailler dans la vie
moi je pense qu'un ouvrier du bâtiment
ou qu'une une aide-soignante dans
l'ehpad
parce qu'il commence à travailler plus
tôt dans la vie parce qu'ils ont eu des
formations plus courtes ils peuvent
partir plus tôt à la retraite mais qu'en
revanche des gens qui ont fait de plus
longues études et donc qui ont des
métiers moins pénible parce que c'est
comme ça que ça se passe très
concrètement dans ce cas là ils peuvent
partir plus tard
avant tranché le juge de but et ça mais
avant de trancher le sujet mais edouard
philippe il dit une chose c'est qu'on
n'est pas
différents des allemands qui ont choisi
le 67 ans mais il ya une différence avec
l'allemagne et ça on pourrait s'en
occuper avant même l'élection
présidentielle
c'est la question de l'employabilité des
seniors et de la fin de carrière
professionnelle il ya une chose sur
laquelle on est très mauvais dans ce
pays c'est l'employabilité des seniors
depuis très longtemps un est depuis très
longtemps et vous pouvez l'adapter
d'ailleurs c'est pas au carbone 14
mais c'est à une loi dite bouvard de la
lande 1999 c'est au moment où vous
embauchez un senior
le licencié parce que ça peut arriver
dans les contrats de travail moment il
peut y avoir des ruptures et ben ça vous
coûte 3 ou 4 fois plus cher que pour
quelqu'un de plus jeune et donc il n'y a
pas une espèce de racisme anti senior
pour les chefs d'entreprise il ya juste
le risque financier qui peuvent
représenter si jamais il doit y avoir
une rupture anticipée du contrat de
travail donc la première chose c'est de
lever tous les freins à l'employabilité
des seniors et il ya une deuxième chose
qui est extrêmement importante
c'est la question en fin de carrière
professionnelle de la transmission moi
je pense que les français sont pas bêtes
ils savent que si on veut mieux financer
l'école l'hôpital la sécurité la justice
et la transition écologique on pourrait
tous travailler deux heures de plus dans
la semaine et deux en plus dans sa vie
tout le monde s'attend à ce qu'enfin il
est quelqu'un qui le disent franchement
en revanche si on doit travailler deux
ans de plus dans sa vie il faut qu'en
fin de carrière professionnelle on
puisse travailler un peu moins et
transmettre un peu plus et vous en
souvenez peut-être moi j'avais porté une
proposition du groupe démocrate
dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites qu'on n'a pas pu achever
c'était que en fin de carrière
professionnelle on demande à tous ceux
qui ont accumulé une expérience
professionnelle qui ont des
connaissances que il travaille un peu
moins sur les dernières années de leur
carrière professionnelle et c'est
quasiment sûr sur la dernière décennie
que ça doit s'organiser pour transmettre
plus parce que non seulement ça permet
aux jeunes ainsi qui arrivent sur le
marché du travail d'être mieux formés de
disposer toute l'expérience accumulée
mais surtout c'est du respect pour ce
qu'on fait une carrière professionnelle
entière est acquis aujourd'hui quand ils
partent à la retraite du jour au
lendemain alors dit bécoter merci vous
posez vos affaires ici on vous sert un
coup de doha this et vous mangez 3 olive
et on oublie même tout ce que vous avez
accumulé dutil et qui peut être transmis
à la société cette question de la
transmission c'est la question
fondamentale si vous régler le problème
de l'employabilité des seniors et de la
transmission vous ne posez déjà plus du
tout dans les mêmes termes la question
de l'allongement des carrières
professionnelles
oui une étape we invite à auxerre pour
atlantico je voudrais rebondir sur ce
que vous êtes ce que vous avez déclaré à
propos de la du débat entre ligne
identitaire et ligne libérale à droite
est-ce que c'est ainsi qu'il faudrait
lire la bagarre va y avoir la présidence
de la mf
qui se déroule actuellement
c
j'avais pas fait le rapprochement parce
que
[Musique]
alors ça recouvre certaines réalités
mais comme vous l'avez observé
ce ne sont pas deux listes de droite
sont des listes très mélangée avec des
personnalités différentes
moi je vois plutôt
une ligne de responsabilité qui est
porté par mon ami philippe laurent
centriste ami de longue date et une
ligne
d'opportunités
qui est conduite par celle de
d'humeur de cannes
ouais je ne connaissais pas le maire de
cannes
je les ai découverts
pendant la crise covin parce qu'il a été
le premier maire en france a passé son
espace public et ses plages les plages
de cannes à l'eau oxygénée
mois qui a été maire 20 ans
je ne voterai pas
pour avoir un président national des
maires de france pour quelqu'un qui
a une approche scientifique d'alu 2d
lutte contre les épidémies
aussi incertaine la vallée de l'eau de
javel
vous dit fort bien j'ai vu aussi des
mères passer leurs espaces publics à la
javel au bord du lac du bourget où
j'habite
moi j'ai couru à la mairie vous êtes
complètement malade vous êtes en train
d'animer la nappe phréatique à côté du
plus grand lac naturel de france qui est
un joyau extraordinaire et dit oui mais
ça rassure la population
écoute je sais qu'à un moment donné pour
rassurer la population tu peux faire des
choses sans forcément abîmé
l'environnement en fait c'est pas
interdit et moi j'ai le plus grand
respect pour les maires parce que je les
ai été longtemps et ch'est combien c'est
difficile d'affronter cette population
je pense quand même que vit parfois dans
une société politique qui marche un peu
sur la tête ou pour être tranquille
pendant 5 minutes ou se faire un petit
succès d'estimé sur bfm dire on passe
une plage à l'eau oxygénée où on passe
un bon public à la javel
question de nicolas votre bonjour
nicolas domenach je suis derrière
deux choses d'abord il me semble que
vous n'avez pas tout à fait répondu à
une des questions qui vous étaient
posées mais sans doute c'est parce que
vous n'avez pas eu le temps
sur la nécessité de se pousser un peu
pour faire de la place à d'autres
d'autres que vous même dans une future
majorité et jusqu'où vous étiez prêt
vous avoue réduit réduire mais ce
n'était pas ma question ma question
c'est est qu on a vu quelques crédits
qu'on apporte aux sondages que des
électeurs des électorats qu'on croyait
arrimer pouvait décrocher est ce que
vous ne craignez pas que le vôtre puisse
connaître semblable mésaventure si vous
restez au mot d'ordre donné nous 50 plus
autrement écrit qu'est ce qui pourrait
être un peu plus mobilisateur que cette
perspective qui pourrait quand même
peut-être les discuter
alors je vais donc répondre à la
question de nathalie moreau avec nicolas
domenech rappelez bien
vous savez que tout ce sont dans un
mouvement démocrate chrétien en tout cas
c'est son origine évidemment on a tous
un sens de l'abnégation très élevé
ce que je pense pour autant c'est que si
vous regardez la majorité parlementaire
à l'assemblée nationale telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui vous avez un certain
nombre de députés qui ne se représente
pas certains qui ont quitté la majorité
et vous avez bien voulu et je vous en
remercie le faire observer tout à
l'heure certains qui ont rejoint la
majorité à travers le groupe que j'ai
l'honneur de présider mais vous avez
aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines de
circonscriptions qui sont à conserver ou
à reconquérir et de ce point de vue là
je pense que une fois qu'on aura
organisé
cette famille politique central nos
alliés demain ont vocation naturellement
à élargir la majorité dans ces
circonscriptions qui sont aujourd'hui
disponibles donc moi je ne pose surtout
pas le les intérêts politiques des uns
et des autres ou numérique des uns et
des autres précisément parce que
c'est par l'élargissement de la majorité
qu'on pourra bien travaillé si les
électeurs nos produits dans la prochaine
législature est pas en essayant de faire
un espèce de re dispatching interne des
circonscriptions au sein de la majorité
mais ça passe
par
la réaffirmation de ce à quoi on croit
parce qu'effectivement le rapprochement
des deux familles de la majorité
aujourd'hui ça doit surtout servir à
redire aux français là où on veut les
emmener vous avez observé au début de la
législature
qu'à un moment
on avait perdu les français parce qu'on
réforme et à tour de bras et un mois ils
nous disaient on est arrêté un peu
il n'a presque trop alors il fallait
remonter le retard dans plein de
domaines il fallait faire ce que les
autres avaient pas eu le courage de
faire fort bien mais à un moment donné
on avait tellement qu'on savait plus où
on voulait les emmener il faut
réaffirmer ce à quoi on croit
je crois nous croyons que cette famille
politique central elle doit renouer avec
ce qui est un des grands courants de
pensée de la vie politique française qui
est le courant démocrate humaniste
c'est cette ligne là qu'on doit incarner
si on doit rapprocher deux partis
politiques au fond les français se
foutent des partis politiques ils
veulent savoir ce qu'on pense pour eux
il faut les emmener vers savais au fond
je vous aurais dit ça il ya dix ans
moyer dit oh bah la belle nouvelle vous
êtes pour la démocratie monsieur minyana
il mais aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet majeur
ce qui s'est passé en afghanistan en
dehors des conséquences géopolitiques
évidemment on aura à traiter dans les
années qui viennent c'est aussi que des
gens ont prétendu dans le monde que la
démocratie
n'était pas adapté à tous les
territoires et à toutes les cultures je
pense exactement l inverse je pense
exactement que le message de la france
des valeurs démocratiques de la liberté
de la justice sociale du respect des
droits des femmes
c'est un message universel
et sans aller jusqu'à kaboul
tous les débats qui se déroulent
actuellement dans cette pré campagne
bizarre
parfois vénéneuse
présidentielle
c'est aussi des remises en cause un
certain nombre de fondamentaux de la
démocratie française
qu'on puisse affirmer que
les femmes de ta voir une autre place ou
plutôt reprendre la place inférieur qui
était la sienne
dans la vie sociale ce n'est pas la
conception que j'ai de la démocratie
française que l'on fasse une forme de
révisionnisme historique derrière la
console culture
où on voudrait opposer les français
par leur origine
au fond si on réfléchit
au débat qui agite la droite de la
droite aujourd'hui
et
le gothisme je veux pas faire de
raccourcis
qui serait choquant mais
l'une des deux dérives comme l'autre dit
quoi elle réduit l'identité à l'origine
moi je n'accepte pas que mon identité ce
soit seulement mon origine tout comme je
n'accepte pas qu'on réduise ma culture à
ma religion
tout comme je n'accepte pas qu'on
confonde islam islamisme
et bien ces principes là qui au fond
sont ce drone ans au lendemain d'une
crise historique majeur au delà au
lendemain de la défaite de 1870 qui
avait marqué la france comme jamais elle
se croyait le plus beau pays du monde
elle se croyait la plus grande armée du
monde elle avait été battue
la run en parle
et il redit ce cas la france
et redit que la france
ça n'est pas qu'une origine ce n'est pas
qu'une religion ça n'est même pas qu'une
seule langue
c'est un destin
fondée autour
de l'idée de démocratie que nous avons
prévu et que nous avons défendues de par
le monde et qui est bien fondée sur
cette idée que on veut être un peuple
plus libre que les autres
et qu'on a pour passion et pour horizon
l'égalité et la justice sociale dans le
débat actuel
de de la campagne présidentielle je
pense que ces valeurs là elle compte et
que elles peuvent imprimer
une philosophie une spiritualité de
spiritualité dans l'inspiration des
décisions qu'on prendra parce que avec
cette grille de lecture là
c'est pas une réponse idéologique c'est
à dire à chaque fois que l'on vous pose
une question vous apportez toujours la
même réponse quelle que soit la question
c'est cette sensibilité-là qui dira que
demain en matière économique en matière
sociale en matière écologique en matière
territoriales à chaque fois il faudra
être habité par ses passions de la
liberté et de l'égalité
compris de la liberté économique et par
les humanismes social pas beaucoup du
libéralisme pourtant feu jusqu'à destin
était très libéral
il y avait une trouve la plus belle
définition qui avait été donnée du
maquereau nisme
c'était
autant de liberté que possible
autant de solidarité que nécessaire
c'est françois bayrou qui l'avait trouvé
et je pense que il faut qu'on renoue
avec ce cette doctrine est ce récit là
alors moi je dis df jeu
c'est sympa de faire remarquer que je
suis déjà un vieux politique mais je
n'ai pas de nostalgie
je pense que la bonne idée de l'udf
c'était de faire deux français sur trois
mecs l'udf n'a jamais représenté 2
français sur 3 l'udf c'était un parti de
centre-droit
mais je pense que
aujourd'hui toutes les familles
politiques doivent travailler sur
elle-même et redéfinir ce qu'est leur
ligne leurs courants de pensée leur
philosophie nonobstant la pression du
quotidien des élections qui arrivent et
des des réseaux sociaux
mais que la ligne que je vais essayer de
définir en quelques phrases cette ligne
là
elle peut rassembler
des racines de la gauche des
sociaux-démocrates
jusqu'au libéraux à droite en passant
par cette grande famille personnalité
démocrate chrétienne et parfois
démocrates laïques qui était la famille
historique du centre de questions pour
terminer ensuite on va prendre celle de
stanislas
bonjour jean michel lahmi nouvel
économiste à propos du contrôle des flux
migratoires
est ce que la droite est dans une ligne
identité cours après tout cela quand
elle réclame des référendum pour lever
les obstacles juridiques que je vais pas
décrire mes différents objectifs qui
viennent droit communautaire de loi
internationale et donc par rapport à ça
quelle est votre analyse et notamment
sur le fond comment contrôler les flux
migratoires
là aussi je crois qu'il faut savoir
apporter des réponses techniques et
courageuse plutôt que politique et
démagogique la france présidera le 1er
janvier prochain l'union européenne
le sujet des migrations qu'elle soit
pour fuir la guerre pour fuir la misère
ou pour fuir les aléas climatiques
ne peut se régler qu'à l'échelon
européen
et la question du contrôle migratoire ne
peut se poser confronte hier de l'union
européenne
et c'est une définition du droit d'asile
à l'échelon européen
tout comme le la définition
j'allais dire de quotas
d'immigration économique
vous ne pouvez le penser que qu'à
l'échelon de l'union européenne de la
même manière si vous voulez rendre plus
efficaces les obligations de quitter le
territoire
fameux taux de réalisation des oqtf si
vous le négocier avec la puissance de
l'union européenne
vous serez naturellement plus efficace
que si vous le faites seulement à une
échelle nationale
quand je vois les droites donner des
leçons de reconduite du tf les chiffres
sont têtus
en 2012
le taux de 2 d'exécution d occulter f
c'était 12% facile à retenir 2012 12%
aujourd'hui on en 2021 21% donc les
français comprennent pas pourquoi quand
il ya des personnes qui sont identifiés
que mais qui sont
doivent être reconduite ce soit pas le
cas évidemment qu'ils sont ils sont
révoltés mais le sujet 'cependant lance
pavaner sur ces news que monsieur plâtré
hier en expliquant qu' à une épuration
ethnique des blancs dans les banlieues
de chalon sur saône qu'on règle le
problème
c'est moi d'abord je pense que face à un
problème faut trouver une solution pas
un coupable
car racisme existe dans ce pays mais oui
évidemment encore malheureusement et ça
va complètement à l'encontre des valeurs
démocratiques que j'évoquais à l'instant
il ya du racisme des blancs vers les
noirs il est raciste de noir vers les
blancs et parfois des racistes des noirs
anwar
est donc traiter la question du racisme
c'est pas la traiter avec la réponse
unique tout ça c'est la faute aux
musulmans
mais si vous voulez traiter la question
de l'immigration en profondeur vous le
faites à la bonne échelle c'est à dire à
l'échelle de l'union européenne et vous
le traitez naturellement avec des
mesures courageuses y compris
diplomatique s'appuyant sur
l'aide publique au développement que
vous conditionnée à l'acceptation par
les pays d'origine des reconduites à la
frontière
l'inflation est journaliste indépendant
juste une petite question sur le une
tribune qui a été signée hier publié
hier par le monde deux cents soit 75
députés qui demandent le retour en
france des 200 enfants détenus dans les
camps en syrie et de leur maman pour les
enfants pour des raisons humanitaires et
les mamans pour des raisons sécuritaires
je ne sais pas si vous avez signé cette
tribune et quelle est votre position à
ce sujet je suis jamais tribune
mais
je vais vous donner un avis j'entends
dans le pays des gens qui nous disent
mais attention ces enfants vont être
marqués sur toutes les premières années
de leur vie de choses tellement terrible
et dramatique que on doit les laisser là
bas
au même titre que je pense qu'on réduit
pas
une identité à une origine
je pense que on peut pas condamner à
perpétuité
des êtres humains et en particulier des
enfants en vertu des premiers drames
qu'ils ont vécu dans leur vie moi je
pense que la responsabilité et je pense
que la grandeur de la france c'est de
les accueillir mais de les accompagner
il ya depuis longtemps dans notre pays
un angle mort
au sein de l'école dès l'école
maternelle
c'est la question de l'accompagnement
par des psychologues
vous avez des enfants qui selon
par qui ils ont été élevés là où ils
sont nés ou ou avec des expériences
connues ou non
sont moins bien armés que les autres
dans la vie
moi je pense que si un grand pays comme
la france n'est pas capable de se doter
de psychologues pour aider ceux qui ont
moins de chance dans la vie à sortir de
leur état et si on n'est pas capable
d'avoir un accompagnement social
psychologique affectif pour les 250 go
ce qui n'ont pas choisi de naître là bas
on n'est pas tout à fait la france
merci patrick mignola merci à tous à
bientôt